Continuing in al-wajiz fi kitab al-salah
regarding the
prerequisites to prayer.
These following chapters are going to be
dealing with the various prerequisites,
various conditions of salah.
Starting with upon whom salah is
obligatory
and
continuing on into all nine
conditions of prayer.
Then
we will get into the pillars and
later obligations.
But
just other chapters,
before we break down exactly what the
any
inner workings of salah are
and what constitutes
a
a valid prayer from an invalid prayer,
we are going to discuss a full picture
of how the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam was narrated to have prayed
most of the time. So, 95% of the time,
given he was in good health
and what he consist- consistently did
when he prayed,
we will have a complete salah
description
of how he used to pray most of his life,
sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
from takbir all the way until at taslim.
So, salah is obligatory upon who?
Upon whom?
[Silence]
So, salah is obligatory upon every
Muslim
who is of age,
of age meaning age of puberty,
and
his sanity or her sanity is intact. So,
every sane
pubescent
any every sane Muslim over the age of
puberty.
So, here
we have
three conditions that the author
mentions. Number one, Islam, person is
Muslim.
Number two, the person is at least of
the age of puberty.
Number three, the person is sane.
And now, we'll see that in a lot of
chapters, these conditions are
repetitive, all right?
But, we have to remember the definitions
that we gave to these things early on.
So, for instance,
before
when discussing fasting
and
discussing
ghusl and some other things,
we mentioned
what is the age of puberty.
We said the age of puberty
is one of three things happens.
And for girls,
there is a fourth.
Right?
Three things
that may that are an indication
that this child has reached the age of
puberty.
And what that means is this child may
not be an adult
socially,
but in Islam,
they are held responsible for their
actions at this age.
Meaning in the hereafter.
Meaning if they do not pray, they will
be held accountable by Allah.
If they do not fast, they'll be held
accountable. If they commit a crime,
they'll held be held accountable.
Right? Three
for boys and girls, and a fourth one for
girls.
Do we remember what they are?
What
[Arabic recitation]
Nabtil Ana, right, which is that hair,
pubic hair, that hair grow around the
private parts, pubic hair.
Very specific type of hair that grows
around the pubic parts.
This pubic hair
means that this child has reached the
age of puberty. Okay, that's one.
Age 15, okay, and three
Al-ihtilam, which means that
sexual maturity, that the child has a
wet dream,
right, or sexual maturity. The
the the
having of climax, sexual climax. This is
three
for boys and girls, and for girls,
there's an additional one, which is
menstruation.
These four indicators
mean that this child is what?
Is of the age of puberty.
That means that both angels are writing.
In the Before this age of puberty,
one angel is writing.
Right? The angel of good deeds is
writing. As soon as the child is able to
is able to discern right from wrong,
right from left,
is able to have a coherent intention,
usually by the age of seven, but some
much earlier than that.
Could be as early as 4 years old or 5
years old, the angel of good deeds is
writing.
But when does the angel of sin and bad
deeds begin to write?
At the age of puberty.
Right? Okay.
The second or the third thing that the
author mentions is
Al-aql.
That the
person is sane.
Now, remember, sanity has very different
definitions based on the context, but in
Islamic law
we define sanity. Do we remember what
that definition is?
Being able to hold a coherent intention.
If we were to ask this person, "Why are
you doing this?" they will give us a
coherent answer
as to why they're doing this. Do you
know what the difference is between
insanity and stupidity is?
This is a very interesting topic. You
ever think about that?
What's the difference between stupidity
and insanity?
Huh? One of One of them, we give them a
pass. Someone's insane, we give them a
pass. What The other, we do not give an
excuse. Someone is stupid, we don't
allow them We don't give them a pass for
that.
The difference between insanity and
stupidity.
Ibn al-Jawzi has an entire book on this
subject
[Arabic recitation]
al-Mughaffalin.
And he says that in this book, the only
disease that Isa ibn Maryam could not
cure
is stupidity.
And what is the difference between
insanity and stupidity?
They say the difference between insanity
and stupidity
is that
a person who is insane
has an incoherent goal,
but they go about it in a coherent
manner.
Whereas
a person who is
or stupidity
is having a coherent goal.
The goal is correct, but going about it
in an incoherent manner.
So we have goals.
And then we have means to those goals,
right?
Insanity
is that a person has an incoherent goal.
The goal itself is crazy.
But they go about it
in a correct way.
if that were a real truly
coherent goal, I would do that too to
achieve those ends.
Whereas stupidity, it's the opposite.
They have a coherent goal.
But the way they go about achieving that
goal
is
very incoherent. So I'll give you an
example.
Once there was a king
and he loved doves.
You know, he used to keep pigeons.
And ,
you know, he had this huge city that he
was the king of.
And , you know, in a city, usually the
city has walls and these walls have
gates. So you close the gates, open the
gates, right?
And so
someone left some of the cages open.
And so when the king saw that the cages
were left open and that some of the
pigeons were escaping,
he sent out a command to lock the gates
to all of the city walls.
Okay?
This is stupidity or insanity?
Stupidity.
He wants to keep The goal is to keep the
pigeons inside of the city, right?
That's a coherent goal.
But the means he went about it, closing
the city
gates, well, the pigeons fly. They don't
go through the gates.
Right?
The other way
is
insanity.
Insanity is a person has
a coherent goal
or they have a an incoherent goal,
but the means they go about
is what?
Is is correct
for the goal, but the goal itself is
unclear. It's insane. And this is the
difference between insanity and
stupidity.
These two things are conflated in modern
society today.
However, in Islamic law
when a person is considered insane, say,
what is this person who is sane? It's a
person who is able to hold a coherent
intention.
Meaning the goals that they have in mind
are coherent. They make sense.
[Arabic recitation]
That's your mission to turn it off.
Okay?
I hear by
do you
You are accountable to that right there.
[Arabic recitation]